δι ότι σίγουρα δε θα συνταξιδοτηθώ αλλάγια μέναν τω σημαντικό είναιότι ότι έχω κάνει δεν
κ έχω κάνει τ τελευταία όλα τα χρόνια της ζωίσμου και όταν ιμούν ψυχολόγωση στο
μακάριο που έλειπα τελειώτες ώρες δι ότι ποτέ τα είνα νιώθε ότι δημόσιες υπάλιλς στο
δικόμου το χτομε μπορούσε να εμαι με ένα ν ωράριο που τέλειωνα η ώρα δυώμιση
επηγαίνενα και σάβατα κια κυριακές οικογένεια μου έμαθε να ζεί με με αυτή την πραγματικότητα
και μετά με το συμβουλίο της ευρώποισης με τη γυρόπατόνα στο εξωτερικόταρο με την επιτο
σθάνουμε ότι οικογέείνι μου καταλαμβαίνει και έχω ότην πλήρι στήριξη τους ότι δεν την είχα
δεν θα μπορούσαν να είχα προχωρήσει και αυτό για μέ ένα ε πάρα πολύ σημαντικό
τονανιώθουν και εκείνει ότι η γουρόπατό να πρατιγμότος χαρει ια τα παιδιά μο είνα κομμάτι
της ζωής τους και αυτό τους βοήθησε μια δύσκολη περιπέτεια που πέρασε η μητάρα τους
με την ιγία της να εείναι κάτι που είναι μια θετική εμπιρία νιώθουν περήφανι και
εκείνι ότι υπάρχει αυτή οργάνωση και τι συμμετίχαν τι ταν πολύ πιο μικρί στη δραστηριοποιήση
τότε ι αυτόοικογέίναι είναι ένα σημαντικό στήριγμα για μένα και ρώτηση τον κατομυρίο για με
το κλίσιμο να σάς γινόταν πρόταση να παραμείνεται επιτροπος θα μένατε είχα αποφασίσει από μόνυμο
που ξέρεται ότι θα εφεύοτα νιώθω πάρα πολύγεμάτι από αυτή την εμπιρία η οποία τρέχει
ακόμη νιθο σθάνουμε ότι ελπίζω να έχω δώσει των καλύτερο μου αυτό και επίση σεσθάνομε
και με όταν ινουν στη βουλή εχαλς